despite the grim national numbers things
are looking a lot better here in
southern nevada as for schools we're
just one week away
from some younger ccsd students
returning to the classroom
for hybrid learning thank you for
joining us at six i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez elementary schools
welcoming educators back on campus today
as a step in the transition plan
our team covering this process step by
step tonight so let's go to 8 news now
reporter kristen drummond who visited a
northwest valley elementary school
to see how they're preparing
[Music]
welcome back to campus it's a little bit
overwhelming
there's a lot that we have to kind of
clean up and get ready for
why don't you hold off on your question
most pre-kindergarten to third grade
teachers report to gerheim elementary
school on monday
they're back in classrooms to prepare
for students starting hybrid learning
next week it's been a very interesting
day you know people stepping foot on
campus sometime for their first time
i've had some new staff again that had
never been on campus ever i have to go
to my meeting
ryan lewis is principal and calls the
task exciting but
daunting so it's just like starting a
first day of school all over again
we got all of these cameras
librarian michelle zamora unpacks boxes
with tripods and headphones as well
she needs to organize them so teachers
can live stream lessons for students at
home
making sure that the teachers have all
the equipment that they need in their
rooms
every teacher has at least one group
meaning cohort a
or b that they will be servicing in
person and then the remainder of their
students they will be actually serving
in the distance learning capacity at the
same time teachers like kristin
palmatier continue
their final adjustments to ensure
students are safe in classrooms
making those final tweaks of how many
kids are going to be here
making sure they're all spaced out for
example in this second grade room
normally four
students sit at each table but to make
sure everyone is safe there will only be
one child
here i've had my ruler help measuring
everything taking precautions before the
big day
kristen drummond 8 news now now there
are more than 220 elementary schools
while all follow a district plan
families can expect variations on each
and every campus